show me your statistic before you make
wild statistics
day 33 of kicking trees till I get shins
of Steel oh my God
I'm all for training your shins but why
it's such a sharp object that's gonna
break your skin
baccateria is gonna set it and create a
septic arthritis
whoa this is so cool not MediCal at all
but I love the break
I'm talking about
[Applause]
oh oh oh oh
just in case anyone wanted to know what
my fingerprint looks like oh it's a
heart I love it probably makes the best
Valentine's Day cards okay we have a big
trampoline and I don't know what that is
bouncing
oh it's Gonna Fly it's gonna fall oh
honestly that's concussion next spasm
whiplash injury counter coup injury lots
of problems you got to be careful with
head injuries man this is bad because
not only did he get hit in the head and
his neck like Snapped but then he landed
and he hit his head again doctor I think
I have a fear of long words me too
sounds like a classic case of
hippopotomonstrosesquippedaliophobia no
way that's a real world
I have just a specialist for you her
name is Dr Ann oh Mt
disestablishmentarianism okay that's
this is not really
wait what is that stethoscope that he's
got on that looks like it's from like
the 1910s
okay we got a basketball it's bouncing
it's he's dodging it dude that was close
oh gotta be careful with testicular
injury there you could have a serious
problem the hospital wondering why
nobody used that
I know I push for help there's a spider
oh yeah you don't want to push you need
that much help
yeah the hospital's got to do a better
job cleaning that up
okay what's happening here so Rodeo
they're pulling her oh no these things
are terrible okay I don't like this at
all oh the centrifugal force on your
brain is just so bad like it's just
really unnecessary and she's gonna feel
horribly dizzy the endolymph fluid
that's within your semicircular canals
and the little crystals that are in
there that help you gauge position and
have your equilibrium going they keep
going it's through inertia and as a
result you start spinning and feeling
like you're continuing to move so
I don't envy her I just woke up but I'm
about to eat three cloves of garlic um
for like a natural antibiotic okay I
mean
two two why can't you just stop and say
I like three cloves of garlic and I
think overall it's probably a healthy
thing to do because I'll be with it then
I have a few spoonfuls of probiotic
coconut yogurt I normally add a little
bit of cinnamon for a good luck good
luck at least that's one's not medically
inaccurate I fine add cinnamon to your
yogurt for good luck I'm with that clean
this is um a powder to help with your
gut no it's an immunoglobulin
concentrate I don't know yeah exactly
repeat that again I know
I'm gonna try chlorophyll again cleaner
brand um but to detox the body and detox
the body we all need to detox the body
how have we been alive for Generations
without detoxing our bodies man it's
it's incredible it's incredible what
these supplement stores sell to people
and my curiosity and questions to
individuals like this is when you walk
into a supplement store and you see a
hundred thousand items that have
ridiculous claims about cleaner skin and
this and that and yet all those problems
still exist in the people going to the
store aren't you skeptical if I
prescribed a patient who has acid reflux
a prescription drug and it never helped
them you don't think I'll ask some
questions
something bad's about to happen I feel
it medically I'm concerned oh nope he
just went straight for the the butt drop
see that's not gonna feel great on the
sacrum seven seconds to detect stroke
Alzheimer's brain problems I love it
because none of these things are related
to one another at all except they happen
up here overlap index and middle finger
touch your thumb and ring finger if the
little finger can move freely the brain
is healthy
[Music]
[Laughter]
my pinky finger is moving but after
reading that and listening to that my
brain is no longer
it's gonna be a mean skin burn there
I love helmets I love helmets too man
they protect our brain I've been
drinking my own urine for 17 years
you know what's wrong with you as soon
as you drink your morning pea oh and too
much salt too much caffeine
why don't you just control the amount of
caffeine you take in or the amount of
salt you take in why do you need to
taste it The Universe telling me signs I
don't want to hear renting all over my
for you page lately has been eight
papaya seeds to get rid of parasites I
did this parasite cleanse and I've been
pooping worms I'm a holistic
nutritionist and I haven't done a
parasite cleanse in ages so I'm thinking
is this what the universe is trying to
tell me I know it's what you were
searching so the universe just gave it
back to you because that's how the
algorithm works it's not predictive 80
of people have parasites hey 80 percent
of people have parasites show me your
statistic before you make wild
statistics three steps to get glowing
skin without touching your face sleep
well hydrate well eat nice enriched
foods like beets Glide up in your neck
to your ears you mean get a massage they
stimulate the nerve endings that lead to
the release of endorphins cool so um
yeah if you get a massage you'll feel
good and I don't know if that's
considered medical advice or not to
avoid stringing your eyes while working
you should try the 20 20 20 oh I love
the 2020 rule every 20 minutes for 20
seconds look 20 feet away for every 20
minutes you work then you look at
something that's 20 feet away then watch
anime for 20 hours I did not expect that
no actually watching anime for 20
continuous hours not good for the eyes
oh my God I have the best advice for
women in business get your ass
up and work what's happening right now
with her eyes I feel is manufactured
because it there's some kind of split
screen effect on her face that's copying
with what with one side of her face is
doing as an experienced Medical
Professional I see the arteries going
within her eyes and they're following
the same trajectories on both sides and
I don't find that to be feasible by the
way I'm not paying attention to what
she's saying right that's fake I don't
know
POV you unplug the beeping things at the
hospital and all the patients started
sleeping better okay you know what you
shouldn't do this but alarm fatigue is
real if you have alarms going off for no
reason and you start ignoring them
because you know they're for no reason
that's really dangerous because then you
could tune out alarms that actually
matter so please if you feel an alarm is
going off constantly and you're not
responding to it because you know you
don't need to turn it off so that when
you do hear an alarm you react and by
the way there should be quiet times at
night so patients can rest because they
need to rest and recover we don't fix
patients patients fix themselves
please help me why my eyes hurt so bad
it looks like you just have a
subcontractival hemorrhage I mean I
don't know for sure please I'm not
joking they burn bro well if they burn
that means you've probably got something
in the eye but in most cases the biggest
thing about a subcontractival hemorrhage
is patients worrying that something bad
is going on but in reality they come in
we rule out other issues like a scratch
cornea brain lesions by doing a
neurologic exam reflexes we just make
sure they're okay then we send them home
and say you'll be fine
[Music]
wow I'm not gonna lie aesthetically this
product looks cool I have a feeling and
I kind of wish I bought it for this
video it's probably garbage here's my
concern I think your skin gets caught in
Between the Wheels I want if anyone's
used this product leave me a comment
down below I'm worried about your skin
getting caught in there but if it's good
let me know
it smokes oh what's happening my cut is
insane shout out to my barber dog my
assumption is there's some kind of
allergic reaction happening there's
edema and then it's pitting edema so she
pressed in that area and while it's
coming back she made a video
[Music]
Windows Ah that's all hyper extended
knee right there
oh
oh does she have an artificial eye wait
what was that
I need you to explain and I have no idea
to remove a contact lens I don't know I
don't know that looked like a Nerf gun
bullet
okay this looks traumatic in nature or
it could be congenital
you got it oh yeah I feel like I've seen
this guy's finger before
see what I think is happening here is
injury to the middle layer of the skin
or the proteins that connect the
epidermis to the dermis and as a result
there's edema in there and fluid in
there so that's just his finger moving
but then
the nail should be moving too so I don't
know what's going on
oh what is this this looks like a burn
of some kind there's a nickomycosis so
there's some fungal infection of the
nails there the feet are quite red so
there could be potentially signs of
infection whether fungal or bacterial I
mean blisters caused usually by friction
or heat or something happening damage
wise there are also autoimmune
conditions like bolus pemphigoid but
usually those are all across the skin
not just in a single location like this
oh man I wonder what happened here
maybe like a heating pad was left on the
skin and it burned the skin because
that's what it looks like happened wow
that's a big blister lots of Edema there
but also it looks like that person has
swollen ankles as well so I'm having
some kind of dependent edema or perhaps
congestive heart failure leading to
lower extremity edema
foot scraping
yeah some foot scraping transported into
a buttering bread no God please no no no
have you heard about the old wives tale
about the potato in the sock overnight
curing the flu I've seen this on five
minute crafts and it made me very angry
it will clean your
cleanup fever so she had the chills okay
just so you're aware the reason you have
fever the reason you have chills is
because your body gives you chills so
you shiver you raise your temperature of
your body Therefore your immune cells
actually start functioning at a better
capacity viral cells have a tougher time
replicating within your body don't know
what rolls potatoes have in this and in
the morning you just take them out and
I'm always amazed at what it looks like
look at that look how black you know
what's also black if you leave it out
avocado and you don't even need a virus
or a parasite for that it's just like
the potato has sucked all the disease oh
my God the potatoes sucked all the
disease or it oxidized just like an
apple does or an avocado but I like to
leave the other piece of the potato cut
up on the counter so I can compare it
yeah do you know what the difference is
your poor child's sweating all over the
potato so it's oxidizing faster dark
circles or puffiness under your eyes the
chances are your kidneys are not
flushing out toxins
hot man what if it's just your face
shape what if that you didn't get a good
night's sleep poor is dehydrated now if
you see an ayurvedic practitioner or
even a Chinese medicine expert they can
look at your face or your tongue and
tell you what's wrong with your body no
they can't like what if they have cancer
and you're telling them it's because
their kidneys are dehydrated yes you
could be dehydrated when you're
dehydrated your kidneys suffer they
don't filter your blood as well so like
all that stuff could be true but the
fact that you're so sure of it is where
you're wrong your lungs are the lower
part of your face no your lungs are here
in your chest cavity and your stomach is
the upper cheek no and your stuff it's
also in your abdomen has nothing to do
with your cheek in your temple area
right here
it's connected directly to your liver no
it's not there's in fact besides the
blood that goes in your liver during
points of circulation that also ends up
here there is no connection between your
cheeks or your face or your temple and
your liver oh or if there is some kind
of jaundice condition and the area is
turning yellow but whatever this person
is saying is horribly inaccurate needs
to be taken down mouth taping let's talk
about why you should be taping your
mouth shut every single day before you
go to bed after she was gonna say so you
don't bother your partner or some joke
thing breathing through your mouth
contributes to a host of issues
including bad breath gum disease
cavities brain fog and a weakened immune
system some of these things yes bad
breath gum disease cavities true brain
fog weakened immune system now we're
starting to get a little into the quack
space because that's not exactly true
maybe you can have a higher propensity
for getting sick but that doesn't
necessarily mean you have a weakened
immune system brain fog also very
subjective and most people myself
included breathe through their mouths at
night vaping your mouth shut before bed
completely prevents that well first of
all doesn't completely prevent it
because that's a very small piece of
tape number two before doing this you
really should talk with your doctor to
see why it is that you're breathing
through your mouth at night some people
have obstructions in their nasal
passageways that could require treatment
whether medical or surgical both are
options some people have allergies and a
simple nasal steroid spray can help and
do wonders for them some people can just
take over-the-counter oral medications
others might realize that they have a
polyp obstructing their sinuses and as a
result they can have great results with
surgical options or you could have
really bad obstructive sleep apnea and
you'd benefit a lot from a CPAP device
so like this is where like the tick tock
may be some good advice turns into
drastically over hyped advice that can
become potentially dangerous but it is
so easy it doesn't come off overnight
and you're going to have the best sleep
ever I hate when people make these
claims you'll have the best sleep ever I
just I can't say that to my patients who
are suffering with insomnia like that's
the difference between a random person
making a video on Tick Tock versus a a
doctor giving advice I have patients who
are truly suffering and having really
bad times in their lives because they
can't sleep and if I promise them great
sleep and the best sleep ever with this
piece of tape and they don't get it that
trust is completely broken but in
general breathing through the nose is
best so like whatever strategy you have
to do to do that after speaking with
your doctor I'm all for trying different
things and if you do breathe through
your mouth there are mouth sprays that
you could use to keep your mouth a
little bit more lubricated like dry
mouth sprays
check out this Draw My Life video of me
coming to America I know you'll enjoy it
the animations are fire as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]
foreign